like i i first my like first foot in the  industry was a paid feature it's  actually jelly roll that was the first  one and only feature i bought and i was  like my foot in so well was that like  2012 that was 2012. yeah actually  highlight saw me last night and showed  me a video of me and jelly from [ __ ]  nine years ago i was like that's so  crazy because i first met jelly in 2014  13. yeah he was a i paid him like  i hope he's not mad at me for saying  this but i paid him like 250 dollars at  first he was like man [ __ ] it he [ __ ]  with my managers he's like [ __ ] pay for  my studio time and i'll come do it oh  wow that was like my first like foot in  i guess to the game was that uh before  cash money yeah pre-cash money wow the  song never even came out it's called  they knows like bro i'm in a triple x  white t riding in these dunks in florida